become a Thunderbird pilot it takes a
lot of practice and experience in order
to apply for the team we have about 10
years of fighter experience a minimum of
750 fighter hours hopefully you're one
of the three pots that are selected each
year for the team the mission of the
team is to represent the Air Force and
to do it with the pride precision the
professionalism that the Air Force shows
on a daily basis
ensure that we're all operating off the
same sheet of music we begin by
executing a mission brief so everybody
has no doubt in their mind about what's
about to happen we fly twice a day every
day just to make sure that you have the
consistency within the the flying skills
to be safe the communication with the
team is very very important so
everything that we say in a tone of our
voice see 109 right track typos out
contactor how we're saying things the
inflection that we use is what they're
keying off of to make sure that they're
in the correct position and they know
where they need to go at what time the
margin of error for flying these
airplanes this close to each other is
very small you're flying these aircraft
over moms and dads and sisters and
brothers and grandparents and so there
is no movement at all on safety
with any operations you're always going
to hit roadblocks all the pilots are
never perfectly a position but they're
always correcting to get back in
position but it's the immediate reaction
and getting back to step position which
allows for the safe execution of
information